So, I’m super excited to bring to you another lesson featuring
one of my favorite movies: Harry Potter!
This time, we'll focus on the rivalry between
Hermione Granger and Draco Malfoy.
But before we get into the lesson, if you are new here,
I want to invite you to join our
community of over 4 Million learners
who are discovering how FUN
learning English can really be, like Emily.
So every week we make 3 lessons
to help you understand fast speech
without getting lost, without
missing the jokes, and without subtitles,
but if you don’t hit that subscribe button and the
bell down below, then you might miss them!
As you saw at the beginning of this video, Draco despises others
who weren't born in a traditional wizard family, like Hermione.
We’re now going to watch a few moments when
Draco abused his position of privilege,
humiliated and teased his colleagues, which culminated
in Hermione eventually punching him in the face.
By the way, wouldn’t you love to be able to understand the
Harry Potter movies, even without subtitles?
Well, in our Fluent with Friends course, we will give you the
resources and knowledge that you need
to understand some of your favorite
TV series and movies, even without the subtitles.
You will master the three keys that you need to unlock confident
comprehension: Vocabulary, Pronunciation, and Cultural Context.
You can try it absolutely free right now
by joining our free, 3-part masterclass.
Click up here or in the
description below to sign up.